Narrator:
Tonight special guest shark,
billionaire founder
of Paul Mitchell,
John Paul DeJoria
joins the sharks.
In the tank,
hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks
in hopes of
getting an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
Can I finish
the rest of my information?
[ Laughing ] Oh, man!
It's the worst pitch
I've ever seen.
Narrator: The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll
walk away with nothing.
Johnny, tell your dad
he's a great man.
[ Voice breaking ]
I thank God
that I got to work
with that man.
He's an innovator.
He taught me
everything I know.
Narrator:
If the sharks hear a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money.
I'll give you the $400k.
I'm gonna make you
the same offer.
Silence, please.
Truth is,
you built a brand.
You know what you're doing.
We got a deal.
Not that deal.
Not that deal?
Oh, no.
O'Leary:
This is the shark tank.
There's nothing else like it
on earth.
Narrator:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Mark Cuban, notorious
billionaire entrepreneur,
tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas mavericks.
Lori Greiner, the queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents and
has launched over 300 products,
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in retail sales.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand fubu,
with over $6 billion
in retail sales to date.
John Paul DeJoria
is a prolific philanthropist
and entrepreneur
behind widely known
luxury brands
such as Paul Mitchell
and Patron.
First into the tank
are best friends from St. Louis,
with what they believe are
better, safer cleaning products.
Hello, sharks.
My name's Kevin Tibbs.
And I'm Tim Barklage.
We're the founders
of better life,
and we're requesting
$400,000
in exchange for 7% equity stake
in our company.
[ Chuckles ]
Better life is a unique
line of cleaning products
that will revolutionize
the way people
think about cleaning.
Our products are natural,
they're safe,
and they work better than
the chemical cleaning products
on the market today.
Tim and I both have
young kids the same ages.
When our kids started
crawling around the floor
and putting everything
into their mouths,
we really became concerned
about the products
we had in our home.
And with Kevin being
a formulation chemist,
I put him to the challenge
to create something
that was safe and effective.
Tim and I are gonna show you
just how well they work.
You think soap scum
and hard water stains are tough?
This is spray paint
on this tile right here.
All right, we're gonna put
some of our cleaning product.
And this product --
it's a cream scrub.
No harsh chemicals.
There are no fumes
to this product.
And it's
completely safe.
You don't need gloves,
gas masks, anything like that.
Now, that's from
a plant-based product.
This is what
we're talking about.
Unbelievable cleaning.
Now, this is
really impressive.
This is
a head-to-head competition
against a national leading-brand
chemical disinfectant.
First thing we're going to do
is take raw chicken,
and we're going to spread it
across this piece of countertop.
Stop the madness.
[ Laughs ]
Now, I'm going to
swab that surface
and put it
in this meter,
and this is going to show us
what's left behind.
Any reading over 200
is a dirty surface.
And we get 8,840.
So, as you might imagine --
we've got raw chicken here --
this is
a very dirty surface.
Now,
Tim is going to take
this leading-brand
chemical cleaner,
which is a disinfectant.
Now, I'm going to do
the same thing.
I'm going
to swab that side.
And we get a reading
of 433.
Oh, God.
Now I want Tim to clean
this side of the countertop
with our
What-ever! Cleaner.
All natural.
There are no fumes
in this product.
I'm going
to swab that surface.
44.
And the funny thing
I want to point out here
is on this product,
it is covered
with warning statements.
It even says on the back
that you need to wash
with soap and water
after you've used
this product.
It's a cleaning product.
I want to point out
one thing.
Not only
do we do a better job,
but these products
are safe.
How safe, you ask?
That safe.
Sharks, who wants to help us
create a better life?
How long have you been
selling those products?
We launched
about four --
a little over
four years ago.
And how much have you sold
last year?
In the last 12 months,
we've done about
$2.1 million in sales.
Greiner:
Oh, wow. [ Laughs ]
Really? And who do you
sell it to, please?
One of our biggest customers
is Whole Foods,
regional grocery chains
across the country,
places like Crate and Barrel,
as well.
Sure.
What do you sell it for?
$5.99 to $6.99.
Can I look at it?
Please.
DeJoria:
What is your net?
Yeah, last year we made
$115,000 pre-tax.
Pre-tax.
$115,000.
So, your net's about 5%.
A little more than that.
Why are you
netting so little?
Yeah.
Well, it's actually 7%,
but we're dumping everything
into our brand.
We have very, very little
that --
is there anything proprietary
about your formulation?
There is.
But the reality is --
J.P., can't you
do a chemical report on it,
easily,
to get the formula?
Yeah.
They can, but I've been
a formulation chemist
for 15 years,
and I can tell you
that reverse engineering
is not so easy.
John: Cash-flow positive,
so the question's going to be...
Correct.
...what do you
need our money for?
Well, we are financially
very healthy,
but we're not simply looking for
a financial partner.
We're looking for
a strategic partner.
And do you think that
any one of us want to
get out of bed for 7%?
In your space,
the all-natural, non-chemical,
are you the largest player
or is there somebody larger?
I don't know
that there are any.
You're the only guy
that can spray it in your mouth
and then clean the walls
with it?
Well, that won't go
into the hospital. [ Chuckles ]
Greiner: I like you.
You're fantastic.
I'm going to make you
an offer.
Because I am the queen
of lightning speed
into all retail.
My offer is going to be
$400,000 for 17%,
and I have
a direct-door policy
right into
bed bath & beyond,
and I also think that QVC
would be a great place
to put the product, as well.
I would never do that deal.
17% is insane.
That's -- that's one store
that you know --
well, I'm just gonna tell you
a little story.
That's never gonna happen.
That's pointless. Pointless.
You know my little
scrub daddy sponge?
I've heard of that.
We, in 8 months,
have hit $13 million in sales.
Wow.
Congratulations.
Our partnership did that,
and I can do that for you.
I saw the greed
here with Lori,
and I'm really ashamed
that she would do
that to you here.
Here's how I'll fix this
for you.
I'll give you a loan,
which doesn't cost you anything.
It's a loan, all right?
It's $400,000
for 3 years.
It has 10% interest on it,
and I want
my equity of 5%.
All right?
Anybody
can give you money...
Bec-because...
...but they can't
get you into retail.
...because I am
your banker.
Not anybody --
I'm Mr. wonderful.
Who can't
get you into retail.
At the end of the day --
at the end of the day,
respects your equity,
as Lori doesn't.
Mine is
12% less expensive.
'Cause I believe
you'll pay back my loan.
You got
a $2-million order tomorrow
from a very large retailer.
You're gonna roll it out
to 80% of their stores.
How are you gonna
fund that?
Well, loans.
Right here.
They're gonna fund it
because they're gonna
do the deal with me.
Right here.
I have made more millionaires
here in the tank
in less than a year
with my deals.
I'm certain that
I will make you a millionaire.
DeJoria:
I have an idea, okay?
What you may not know, besides
the brands that I started,
I also, uh,
am the major shareholder
of John Paul Selects --
we're global.
Not only do we sell it
over the Internet,
but also we have direct
distribution to major stores
throughout different
parts of the world.
Now, for that $400,000,
if you will go 20%,
if Lori's all for it,
I'll split with her 50/50.
Greiner: Sure.
You've got two people
in that industry.
The only concern is,
though, that that's
valuing the company
at less than
our current sales.
But you -- you have --
ding, ding, ding.
O'Leary: What did you guys
just learn?
Now you have
two greedy pigs.
[ Laughter ]
Not one.
What if I give you
$500,000 for 20%?
And Mark is staying quiet,
so hopefully
he'll keep his pie hole shut
and we can do a deal.
What about --
what about something --
what about something
more in the range of
$500,000 for 10%?
$5-million valuation.
Whew.
I mean, we're --
we're sweetening the pot here.
But you also
want us to work for you,
and you're not
valuing that.
That's --
I mean, our --
we're going to be
at $3 million.
Right, we --
we believe in you.
But I think you have
three offers on the table.
Well --
all the companies we
invest in, regardless
of which shark,
get an immediate trajectory
out of the gate.
You have to give up something
for that, my friend,
no matter who you go with.
This is the shark tank.
There's nothing else like it
on earth.
Narrator: Kevin and Tim
have three offers.
J.P. And Lori have offered
$400,000 for 20%,
Kevin has offered
a $400,000 loan for 5% equity,
and Daymond has offered
$500,000 for 20%.
What are you gonna do?
Greiner: Listen, guys.
Here's the thing.
J.P. and I
have revised our offer.
It's $400,000 for 17%.
We already know
when you talked to Mr. Wonderful
that you don't want
just money.
You want strategic
partners that will
take you to the top.
Now close your eyes
and think about it.
[ Laughs ]
You got a good product,
works really great,
but you're gonna have
a lot of competition.
It's not just
a clear-cut deal, guys.
O'Leary: So, basically,
what Lori just said
and J.P. confirmed,
"close your eyes
and let me screw you."
That's basically
what happened.
[ Laughter ]
Barklage: I think --
I think all the offers
are very generous.
We -- we haven't
heard from mark yet,
and we would like
to hear from him,
just out of respect
to everybody.
Mark, tell them
what you're thinking.
Cuban:
I'm willing to do $800k
for the 20%.
But what I'd like to do
is see Lori come in,
because I think
Lori and QVC is the hero.
That's why
I like to work with Lori.
So --
so, is J.P. In the deal?
No, just Lori and I.
If Lori wants to,
where it's $800k against 20%.
I think giving them $800,000
is too high.
I'm gonna
throw you a lifeline here.
You -- you obviously
don't want to take a loan,
so I'm gonna
change my deal.
I'll give you
the $400k for 17%.
That's what I said.
I want to --
silence, please.
I'm making an offer.
[ Chuckles ]
I'll give you
the $400k for 17%.
After you pay me back
my $400,000
at any schedule you want,
you take back 10% of the equity
back to yourself.
Very interesting.
I'm gonna make you
the same offer.
So, there's no interest?
There's no originality,
either.
[ Laughter ]
Since Lori, you know,
ran over J.P.
Like a scurvy dog,
yeah, I'm --
I think that --
I think that if --
J.P., if you want to
do something together,
because I think
they shouldn't ignore somebody
who's been selling products
and chemicals for years...
If you want to come
in half with me on
that, we'll do it.
$500,000 for 20%.
That's expensive.
I don't like it.
Yeah, I would do that
with you.
Okay.
Yeah, I would do that
with you.
All right.
I would love to
hear an offer
from Mark, from Lori,
that looks something like
$500,000 for 10%.
As much as I love
partnering with Mark,
I have to say on this one,
I don't need him.
And, besides,
the amount of work
that I know
I will have to put in --
I want to go lightning-fast.
Mm-hmm.
So, I like the offer
that I gave you.
Cuban: I'd like to do
this with a strategic
partner like Lori,
but that's not gonna
happen.
I'm out.
You know,
this is a defining moment.
So, think carefully,
'cause you don't want
to walk out of here
having an "oh, no" moment.
"Oh, no.
What did I just do?
What did I just lose?"
Narrator: Lori and Kevin
have the same offer --
a $400,000 loan for 17% equity
that drops to 7%
when the loan is paid back.
Daymond and John Paul
teamed up
to offer $500,000
for a 20% stake.
All the offers
are on the table.
What are you gonna do?
Would you like to?
Lori, let's do it.
Yay! Great.
It's gonna be awesome.
[ Chuckles ]
Thank you.
Congratulations.
Better life
is going to be a household name.
Lori will get us there
so much faster.
Narrator: In season 4,
Nicole Townend made a deal
with Mark Cuban
for her stuffed animal laundry
bag company,
Teddy needs a bath.
Done, done, and done.
Whoo!
[ Laughter ]
Narrator:
Let's see how she's doing now.
Townend: Although it was
terrifying going in the tank,
it was the best thing
that's ever happened to me.
For the first time,
my product is gonna be available
at a major retailer.
Oh, my gosh.
Babies "R" Us
has signed on to carry us
in 450 stores nationwide.
So cool.
Before "shark tank,"
we had $12,000 in sales.
Since "shark tank,"
we have over $100,000 in sales
and we're on track
to hit our first $1 million
over the next 12 months.
I have just signed with gund,
the oldest existing
Teddy-bear company in the world.
So many people
contact gund all the time
to ask us how do we
wash our Teddy bears,
and your invention
is genius.
They are taking over all the
manufacturing and distribution,
which allows me
to be in charge of creative,
which is what I enjoy
the most.
Behind it.
Okay, that's great.
The reason I started
this company in the first place
was to be able to stay at home
with my daughter.
I used to spend endless days
behind a desk.
Now thanks
to this licensing deal,
I've been able to move my family
to Hawaii,
and now I spend my days
hunting seashells
with my daughter
on beautiful beaches.
"Shark tank" has made
all of my dreams come true.
Narrator:
Next into the tank
is a 24-year-old entrepreneur
from New York City
with an update
of a classic party favorite.
Hi, my name
is Solomon Fallas,
and my product is the amazing
and versatile 180cup.
I am here seeking
a $300,000 investment
in exchange for
a 15% stake in my company.
Now, we're all familiar with
this simple, red,
disposable cup.
It continues to be
a prominent icon,
so much so
that in the United States alone,
there are over 2 billion
of these used each year.
I have revolutionized
and made this cup better.
My product, 180cup --
it is a fundamental drinking cup
when right-side up,
and when flipped 180 degrees,
it acts as a shot glass
or a container
or even a measuring cup.
Shoot it,
flip it,
or drink it.
With its dual function,
it's a lot more attractive
than the standard red cup.
Let's say you're at a barbecue
or even a sporting event.
You grab a hot dog
and some fries.
You want some ketchup for
those fries without the mess?
No problem.
With the 180cup,
simply flip it over,
and you have a perfectly
constructed, neat container,
perfect for any of your sauces.
180cup is a clear-cut winner
and soon to be a staple
at every barbecue, tailgate,
birthday party, bar mitzvah.
You name it, 180cup is there.
So, who wants to
take a shot with me?
Greiner: [ Chuckles ]
Have you sold any?
Yes.
In under 6 months, we've sold
over 5 million 180cups...
Whoa!
DeJoria: Wow.
...generating
$385,000 in sales.
Where did you sell them?
We're in 570 stores
to date.
Most of our income
is from local mom-and-pop shops
located
around college campuses.
So, you went
to trade shows
and then, like, sold them
to these mom-and-pops or --
no, actually, I took
a very unique approach
to selling these.
Through my social networks
and craigslist,
we offered collegians
an opportunity to make money.
All they would have to do
is connect us
with their local liquor,
convenience, or grocery store.
We'd send them free
samples. If they sold,
they'd place an order.
Depending on that order,
we'd give the collegians
a commission.
Using that process,
we broke 120 stores.
We've received a 92%
reorder rate from those stores.
So, how long have you
been in business?
Six months.
Wow.
Can I see
one of the cups?
Of course.
Check them out.
They're really cool.
These are our 24 pack.
And we're right there
at the same price
as a standard red cup.
That is the beautiful thing
about this product.
How'd you
come up with this idea?
Went to go visit
my brother in college.
He was hosting
a party for his fraternity.
I personally
didn't go to college,
so I walked in and
I was just immediately in shock.
I counted 900 cups.
There must have been
200 people there.
His friend drops a
shot of whiskey in the
drink and it hit me.
I said,
"these cups are everywhere.
"Someone's making
a ton of money off this.
Why not apply this process
to the red cup?"
John: Well, what --
what -- what about this?
$300,000 for 20% --
you give me the
answer right now.
Oh, wow.
[ Sighs ]
O'Leary:
Well, you know...
You should say yes.
...I still have a couple
of questions before
I make him an offer.
I'm gonna pull it
off the table in a second.
$300,000, 20% right now.
[ Sighs ]
Ooh.
Narrator: Solomon is seeking
$300,000 for 15% of his company,
but Daymond shocked everyone
by immediately offering
$300,000 for 20%,
which lowered his valuation
from $2 million
to $1.5 million.
O'Leary:
Well, you know...
Cuban: You should say yes.
...I still have a couple
of questions before
I make him an offer.
I'm gonna pull it off
the table in a second.
$300,000, 20% right now.
[ Sighs ]
Well, you don't know
if there's a better offer.
[ Sighs ]
Can I finish
the rest of my information?
[ Laughing ] Oh, man!
I want -- I want you to know
how big this can get.
It's getting --
it's gonna -- okay.
If you saw a $100 bill on
the ground, would you
stop and pick it up
or would you look to
see if there's more
down the street?
Don't let a guy
railroad you on a deal.
You don't know
if there's another offer here.
Right, I'd like
to hear other offers.
Oh, man!
Yeah, no kidding.
Okay.
With all due respect,
I love the offer
and it's a great offer.
I just would love
to hear other offers.
Oh, man.
You gave me time
to think, then,
so, then,
I guess I have to be out.
Wow.
DeJoria:
Is this patented?
Yes.
It's it patent-pending,
or is it patented?
This is
a fully patented product.
We have a utility patent
and a design patent.
Greiner:
So, your market
is college students,
predominantly,
because that's
who's interested in
having shots and beers
constantly.
Speak for yourself.
[ Laughs ]
Well, I-I'd say yes and no,
because
at the end of the day,
where don't you find
the red plastic cup?
How much of your own
money have you put
in this so far?
$175,000.
Cuban: Oh!
Whoa!
I'm more curious
about your college network.
How many people?
How many campuses?
Are they continuing
to sell for you?
Can you put other products
through there?
Yes, definitely.
Currently, we're in
120 stores, over 30 colleges.
There's 3,000 colleges.
There's 6 1/2 million kids
in college.
So, we're basically covering
1% of the market,
and we've generated
$385,000 in sales.
You know, college kids
interact with each other
and with more people
than anyone else.
A friend in Seattle is gonna
tell his friend in New York.
I want to build a brand.
So, some dude's walking around
a fraternity party
doing shots out of
this and that looks
cool, basically,
or playing flip cup
or whatever.
Right.
Because then all of a
sudden, you could start
putting logos on there.
Happy you said that.
See, we came out with these cups
in clear, as well.
So, now, what I created
these clear cups for
was to go after
these spirit companies.
J.P., imagine if you could
send your customers these cups
as a promotional item
with your logo on it.
Not only are they gonna be
drinking your stuff,
but your logo is gonna
be smack in the face
of your customer.
John: I was already
there at the beginning,
because I understood that.
These bobos usually
catch up to me about
10 minutes later, so...
You know, now, we
understand what I was
already thinking, so...
You guys
got any offers for him?
There's something about,
like, doing a shot,
putting it down on the dirty
table, doing a shot again.
I don't know.
Cuban:
A lot of experience there?
[ Laughs ]
Yeah.
I-I understand what
you're saying, but the truth is,
at the end of the day, it is
selling to the college market.
I-I-I guess I'm not into
promoting something
where people
are doing a lot of shots.
But, Lori,
imagine you put this on QVC.
Imagine
what people are gonna think.
I don't think
they'd want it.
I have to be honest.
This really isn't
my kind of thing,
so I'm out.
Look, what you set up
with the kids,
to go out there
and become your sales reps,
I think is brilliant,
right?
You created
something interesting,
but it's niche and
it doesn't match your valuation,
so, for that reason,
I'm out.
All right.
DeJoria:
I personally think that
what you are doing
as an entrepreneur is brilliant.
You're thinking
out of the box.
But I'm
the type of investor
that really has to feel
the passion about something.
If I don't feel it,
I can't really get into it,
so, in this case,
I'm out.
Okay.
[ Sighs ]
Kevin, it's making money.
That's what we both love.
You know, the ketchup
and mustard thing,
that's a load of crap.
We both know that.
This thing
is a bar deal,
and I understand
you've got
a very interesting way
of selling it.
Uh...
I, uh -- I'm out.
When I gave you
a hard offer immediately,
you just
ignored that offer.
My --
my feelings are hurt.
Daymond, with all due respect,
it was just a little too early.
I wa-- I just --
I need to treat this --
I need to --
I need to be fair to myself.
Now I become
a little bit more valuable
because everybody else
fell out.
Would you like
to make me feel better?
Warm and toasty?
And we can go
do shots together?
Truth is, you built a brand.
You know what you're doing.
We got a deal.
Not that deal.
Not that deal?
Oh, no.
Too late.
No, no, no,
no, no, no.
I thought that's
what you were saying.
Uh-oh.
Oh no, my friend.
Uh-oh, I gave away
all my negotiation -- oh.
I'm in trouble now.
So, you didn't accept
my initial offer.
You know you're gonna have
to pay for that.
Could we do the deal
at the original --
original price
and percentage?
We'll run with it.
I work like a dog.
Don't -- don't --
don't ruin this again.
I've working on it
for seven years.
Just -- just give me
another offer.
Make it a little better
than what I initially offered,
because now
it becomes more valuable.
I'd offer you
$300,000 for 23%.
30% and we have a deal.
And I will help you,
and I will license this thing,
and we will
get this thing out there.
I can't give up
30% of my company.
I can't. I've invested
too much time and money.
I'll stick to the 23%.
25%.
2% is not gonna
make or break me.
All right. We got a deal.
All right.
Greiner:
Congratulations.
It almost did
make or break you.
It almost did.
I'm excited.
Give me a hug.
All right.
Congratulations,
Solomon.
Guys, it's been a pleasure.
Thank you.
[ Sighs ]
Towards the end,
I was starting to regret it.
Once they were all out
and I was stuck there,
I knew he had me,
but I partnered
with the right guy --
a guy who built a brand,
and I know he's gonna bring
180cups to the next level.
Narrator:
Next into the tank
is an entrepreneur
from Pleasanton, California,
with a new innovation
in water sports.
Hello, sharks,
my name is Jason Woods,
and my product
is the Kymera body board.
I'm seeking $250,000
for a 20% stake in my business.
Now, for a shark, getting
out in the water is easy,
but for the rest of us,
it can be a real hassle.
A 10-foot stand-up paddleboard
may be light enough to carry,
but it can be
a little boring to ride on.
A jet ski, on the other hand,
can be a real blast to ride,
but up to $15,000
and 1,500 pounds?
You're also gonna need
a trailer,
a truck to tow it,
a launch ramp.
With gas prices
on the rise these days,
a whole lot of expendable income
just to keep it running.
And where's the fun in that?
So, what is kymera?
The world's first all-electric
jet-propelled body board
and one of the most versatile
watercraft ever built.
Kymera combines the lightweight
and portability of a board
with the excitement of a jet
to forever change the way
we experience the water.
I'll have my lovely fiancee
and test pilot, Elise,
demonstrate for us.
Kymera's unique
heads-up riding position
gives you
all the thrill and excitement
of a conventional
full-size watercraft,
but at a much safer speed.
Its simple design
and low center of gravity
also make it easy enough
for anyone to ride.
Just pull the trigger
to control the speed
and lean
in the direction you want to go.
It's that simple.
Check this out.
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
I know with the right partners,
kymera is positioned to be
the biggest hit
water sports has ever seen.
So, sharks, which one of you
is ready to get your fins wet?
Greiner:
I have a question.
Yeah.
When you're on it, the way
that she was positioned,
it looks to me awkward,
like it would hurt your neck.
What you're not seeing
is the fact that in the water,
your weight
is biased to the back.
So the board
actually sits at a slight angle,
and then the front of the board
is actually at a slight angle,
so even if you
go launch this thing
over a wave
six feet in the air,
it's designed
to regulate the impact
and the displacement of water
so that it's a nice, smooth,
easy lay-in.
What's the top speed
of this thing?
It does
about 15 miles an hour,
but it feels
a whole lot faster
when you're that close
to the water.
And how long does it last
on one charge?
We're looking about
30 minutes to an hour.
That's it?
Currently.
Tell us about
the business itself.
How long
have you been in business?
What kind of sales
do you have?
Sure. Um, I started this
whole thing about 10 years ago.
It started out a gas board.
It's now gone electric.
And, basically, I'm as far
as I can go on my own.
At this point,
it's pretty much --
have you been doing it
continuously for 10 years?
Yes.
That's a nice little
sales pitch,
but you didn't tell us
anything about the business.
Basically, to try to
get this thing into production,
I went to kickstarter.
Are these prototypes?
These are prototypes.
You don't have anything
for sale right now.
Correct.
You went to kickstarter.
What happened?
So, we went to kickstarter.
We raised $116,000
in 30 days.
That puts us
in the top half of 1% of --
okay, forget the bull.
You -- you dodge all the facts.
I'm sorry.
Okay, you went to kickstarter.
What was your goal?
Our goal was $250,000.
Why do you think
you failed?
'Cause
a week before we launched,
kickstarter changed the rules
that disallowed multiple sales.
So, I could only
sell one to one person,
and we found out very quickly
no one wanted to buy one.
This is a social product.
John: So, you're --
are you saying --
wait, wait, wait.
No one wanted to buy one.
You're saying
they wanted to buy more?
Exactly.
People wanted to buy one for me
and one for my wife,
or they wanted to buy
a six pack.
No.
It seems to me --
you're just digging
a deeper and deeper hole.
You're making excuses.
This is something --
how -- what was
the price point on it?
The retail price point
estimated about $2,800.
$2,800?
So, $2,800 and you're gonna
buy 2 or 3 or 4?
And, actually,
one of the big --
you'd buy one
and try it out first
and see,
"do I like it?"
How much
of your own money is in it?
It's hard to say exactly,
but I'd say probably about
$130,000 over the last 10 years.
What did you spend it on?!
I mean, you could have
built prototypes,
you could have
sold something.
And sold them.
John: We're trying to understand
why didn't you go out
and just sell
one at a time
and then improve it and take
another affordable step forward.
Right now, there is a market
in the top-end luxury brand
that wants to take this
thing and take it on
their yachts with them.
That's totally a market.
[ Laughs ]
Do you -- do you have
a patent on this?
A provisional patent,
yes, I do.
A provisional patent.
Provisional --
so you haven't filed yet.
Why?
What's stopping you?
It -- it's --
it's the dollars.
You know, it's basically --
John: Jason, wait.
I-I'm sorry.
I didn't get my answer.
If somebody wanted to buy one,
you would just say,
"no,
I don't want to sell one."
No, absolutely not.
I-I-I certainly would.
The problem is I just don't
want to sell something
out of my garage, you know?
John: Why?
Yeah, but, Jason,
you're so full of crap.
What I want to do is get
to the large volume production
so I can sell something
that's affordable
for people who can't
get on the water right now.
O'Leary:
Why don't you tell us,
before you get completely
fried in here,
'cause it's
starting to happen.
I'm starting to feel
sorry for you, 'cause
I'm a really nice guy.
[ Laughter ]
I want to know what your
distribution strategy is.
Like --
he doesn't even
have a product.
He hasn't even gotten
the patent on the product.
I want to know,
if you could --
if you could build it
for $1,200
and you had
10,000 to sell,
how are you
going to sell them?
The initial business plan calls
for direct-to-consumer sales.
Direct to consumer
online or --
exactly.
You want to sell
it through your own
personal website.
Initially.
How are you gonna
drive traffic? Nobody's
ever heard of you.
I have 6,000 Facebook fans.
[ Laughs ]
But -- but these are
prototypes.
You don't have
a product to sell yet.
Correct.
To make these,
you need injection molds.
Those cost
a lot of money,
especially for
something that size.
That's going to be --
about $40,000 to $50,000.
$40,000 to $50,000?
Just for a mold, yeah.
Jason, you're not an
entrepreneur. You're
a want-repreneur.
Every time
we ask a business question,
you hit us with,
"but so-and-so wants it.
"But such-and-such
is this.
There's a huge market
for this."
You had so many
different opportunities
to actually build a product
and go sell it --
over 10 years!
10 years,
you couldn't figure out
how to go and get a product
and sell it!
You're not a businessman.
You're an inventor.
Just know who you are
and be that person
and find somebody else
to run the business.
But it's not gonna be me.
I'm out.
I think
it's a good concept,
but one of
the biggest problems is,
you haven't really
tested this out
with a lot of people.
You know, when you have
a product like this,
you have to worry about
liability.
You have to worry about
people going out there
and getting hurt.
I don't like to be
a part of products
where people can get hurt,
and so, for that reason,
I'm out.
But keep -- keep trying.
Keep going with your
entrepreneurial spirit.
Well, you know he's gonna
keep on trying 'cause
it's been 10 years.
[ Laughs ]
Jason, how do you think
your pitch went today?
[ Chuckles ]
Obviously,
I didn't have sales.
I'm gonna
give it to you straight.
It's the worst pitch
I've ever seen.
I'm out.
[ Sighs ]
You know, Jason,
a $1-million valuation
with no sales was insane.
I'm not the first
to do that.
I know, but you are going to
prove a lesson to others
not to make
this mistake again.
But you have
made deals with people
that have come in
with $1-million valuations
that didn't have sales.
Not this one,
not here today.
That's not gonna happen.
I'm out.
It's just you and me.
Jason, it seems to be
more of a hobby for you
than a full-time job.
One day some of that
could take off,
but at this particular
point, uh...
...I'm out.
Thank you.
Thank you, sharks.
Appreciate your time.
Good luck, Jason.
Thank you.
Good luck.
You know,
he's an inventor.
He's not an entrepreneur.
He's not a businessman.
O'Leary: I hate it.
And I buy a lot of water toys
and I hate it.
I'm pissed.
All they cared about was
"what's the dollar amount?"
Not in my wildest dreams
did I think
they wouldn't be able
to see the potential
in what was sitting
right in front of them.
And they just completely
couldn't see any of it.
[ Birds chirping ]
My name is Johnny Georges,
and I live in Arcadia, Florida,
and I'm the creator
of the Tree-T-Pee.
All right, boys!
Let's do it.
I've been working with farmers
in the irrigation business
for 29 years.
My father is the one
who inspired my business.
He taught me everything I know
and gave me the vision
I have today.
Back in the '80s, when I started
working for my father,
we didn't have water shortages.
Today it's all changed.
Farmers must have
a more-efficient
and less-expensive way
to water their crops
so they can survive.
My product is unique because
it is the start of
a new industry for agribusiness,
and there's nothing like it
on the market today.
My business has had its
ups and downs. That's for sure.
But changing 30 years of the way
people practice their irrigation
takes time.
I need an investment
from the sharks
to grow this business.
I want to promote
water conservation worldwide,
and without them, there's no way
for a guy like me to do that.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Johnny Georges,
and I'm the creator
of the Tree-T-Pee
water-containment system.
I'm asking for $150,000
for 20% of my company.
Tree-T-Pee
is water conservation
and frost protection
at its finest.
Instead of using 25,000 gallons
per tree per year,
we're now only using 800 gallons
and doing a better job,
with a 30% increase
in the growth of new trees
and letting the farmer
get his return on his money
a whole lot faster.
When good people
come together...
...with a noble cause,
great things happen.
And water conservation is
what Tree-T-Pee is all about.
Can you tell us
how it works?
The normal way it's been
has been
without any kind of containment.
A farmer crank on his pumps
and run them 10 hours, 12 hours.
With the Tree-T-Pee,
you contain the water
around each tree.
In about 30 minutes,
you're gonna have three inches
of rain on this tree.
And if I pull
this Tree-T-Pee off,
we're watering nine feet
that way and nine feet that way.
And it's just really
wasting the water.
About 10% gets to the tree.
O'Leary: And nobody figured out
a way to make a nozzle
that shoots down
towards the tree roots?
Yes, sir, but you still get
the wind diffusion from that.
So, I put an irrigation line
on every tree.
That's what's happening.
Yes, sir.
And right now,
before the Tree-T-Pee,
I was putting 25,000 gallons
a year onto that tree.
Yes, sir.
Now I buy the Tree-T-Pee.
I only put 800 gallons.
Yes, sir.
So, I'm saving
a lot of money...
In fuel.
...in fuel and water.
Yeah, well, it's not --
pumping --
it's pumping the water
to the tree costs me
dollars in electricity, okay.
Yes, sir.
Yeah, electricity or fuel.
And the water itself
I got to pay for.
Yes -- no, you don't have
to pay for the water
in the state of Florida --
in California, you do.
But you're selling the
Tree-T-Pee in California, right?
I'm only selling
in a five-county area
in the state of Florida.
Cuban: How much does it cost
to make one?
$2.95.
$2.95?
Yes, sir.
How many have you made,
and how many have you sold,
and what do you
sell them for?
Okay, I have made
127,500 t-pees.
I'm selling them to --
for an average for $4.50 each.
How much?
$4.50 each.
Okay.
I make $1 each.
So, you sell
direct to the farmer.
Yes, sir.
So, you don't have
any distributors in there?
No, sir.
Johnny, do you have
a patent on this?
Yes, sir.
I have a utility patent.
How -- how long does it
usually last? One season?
No, sir.
We leave them on for five years.
Greiner:
Yeah, it never degrades.
That can stay on
for five years?
That durable?
Yes, sir.
These things
last over 20 years.
Okay.
How long have they
been on? What's the
oldest one out there?
1984.
Still out there?
My father was an innovator
in the irrigation world.
We used to bank trees,
to make a long one short.
What that means is we take
a shovel before the freeze night
and cover the trees up
with dirt.
After the freeze,
we'd go pull them off.
We're out in a grove,
and I said,
"dad, can we
do something different?"
So, he came up with
a little-bitty tepee
we'd put on for that night,
and then
pull it off the next day.
So, I look at him and I go,
"let's make these things bigger
and we can leave them
on year round -- look at
the water we could save."
Well, in 1984,
he looked at me and he said,
"oh, you're crazy.
Water's cheap," you know?
"Doesn't matter."
That's changed.
[ Laughs ]
That has changed a lot.
Haven't any distributors
come to you
and said,
"we want to sell this,"
or, "we want to
distribute it for you.
We can take it
way outside of Florida"?
Have you not
called on any of them?
I haven't
called on any of them.
Do you know
what your market is?
Do you know how many --
in Florida, I do.
Yes, ma'am.
But --
we have 42 nurseries.
19 are commercial.
The rest are private with
growers growing their own trees.
And those are the only people
you've sold to.
Yes, sir.
Just the people
you've done irrigation work for.
Just the people I know.
Wow.
This last freeze,
I go out to a grove,
I put out five t-pees.
This woman gets out
and she walks up to me
and she says, "you're
trespassing in my grove!"
And I said, "yes,
ma'am, but I'm trying
to show you something.
"It's getting ready to freeze.
"We have the best
frost-protection device
on the market
right here we could put on."
And -- and she says,
"you've got to go
or I'm calling the police."
And I said, "yes, ma'am.
Here's my card. I'm sorry."
You know,
because these are farmers.
This is their land.
This is their livelihood.
So, a week later, I get
a call from the same woman.
"Hey, Johnny. This is Mrs..."
I said, "yes, ma'am,"
she says,
"I want to pay you
for them five t-pees."
And I said, "yes, ma'am. That's
okay. Don't worry about it."
She says, "well, I want you
to bring me 4,995 more.
Wow.
"The only five trees
I got alive today...
Wow.
...in my whole grove
is these."
Is there anything like this
on the market?
No, sir, there's no
water-containment system
out there
for the micro-sprinklers.
Why only $5?
O'Leary: It's got to be $12.
Why not charge $10 or $12
or $15 or $20?
Because
I'm working with farmers,
and they're buying --
they're not buying one.
They're buying
20,000, 7,000, 10,000. Sir?
But still, not why $10?
Even -- even at 10,000, right,
why not $7?
Well, I've never done that.
I've always tried to be right.
I make $1 off each one.
If I --
I sold 7,000 yesterday.
I made 7 grand.
Johnny, you -- you could see
a partner that --
let's say I was a big
distributor of water
irrigation systems,
and I see this product
and you show it to me,
and you make it
for $2.50
and you sell it for $5,
right?
I'm making it for $2.95.
I sell them for $4.50.
Yeah.
Okay, so, I can't
get involved with you
'cause there's not enough margin
for me as a distributor.
I need to be able to sell it
for $12 at least
so that I can
make some profit
and you can
make some profit, right?
'Cause I'm --
now we're --
there's two of us.
Two mouths to feed.
Yeah, but you're selling
to farmers.
Okay, I get it,
but I'm exploring
where your head's at,
all right?
Okay.
That means that
there's no room in it
for a distributor
that can really scale this up,
'cause you said
every farmer should have it.
Every farm in America that does
something should have this.
Every tree
that goes in the ground
should have a Tree-T-Pee on it.
But in order for
that to happen,
I need a lot of Johnnys --
there's only one of you.
I need like
2,000 Johnnys
calling on farmers
all across the land.
And who is gonna pay
them, Johnny? Who's
gonna pay them?
I'm out.
Johnny.
Yes, sir.
Farmers are
the cornerstone of America.
There may be
a lot of farmers out there
that can't afford
$12 per tree,
but maybe they could afford
$6 or $7.
I'm gonna give you
everything you're asking for --
your $150,000 for 20%.
What you're doing
is right,
and you deserve the chance
to make it big
and do a lot of good.
I'd like to be your partner,
Johnny.
I like everything
you stand for, man,
and I like everything.
Thank you, partner.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
I think that's
a yes, J.P.
Yes, sir.
Okay, man.
Good for you.
All right, partner.
Congratulations.
God bless America.
You show that it works,
man.
Thank you. Thank you.
All right, dude.
All right.
I appreciate it.
Well done, partner.
I'll be a good one, too.
All right.
I love that
you care about the farmer.
Johnny, tell your dad
he's a great man.
He died 12 years ago.
Ohh.
He's still a great man.
He made me who I --
[ sniffles ]
[ Voice breaking ]
We work hard every day.
I worked for that man
for 20 years.
I thank God that
I got to work with that man.
He's an innovator.
He taught me
everything I know.
He was hard on us,
but nobody owes you nothing.
Life is what you make it.
He taught me that.
And he was a great man.
He came from nothing.
Cuban:
You're a star, Johnny.
Man, congratulations.
Thank you.
DeJoria: Superstar, dude.
God bless you, Johnny.
Thank you.
[ Sniffles ]
Come here today
and go in front of the sharks.
I didn't have a clue that it was
gonna be like that, you know?
I'm going home with
a billionaire for
a business partner.
It's all good, brother.
[ Laughs ]
You know? I mean, it doesn't
get any better than that.